(soft music)
- I've been working with marine
mammals for almost 40 years.
Come on up!
Good girl.
When I started working
with seals and sea lions,
good job kiddo,
I was under the impression
that the trainer
was supposed to be in
charge of the session,
not the animals.
Good boy!
That's how most aquariums do it
but I don't think that way anymore.
Good!
(soft music)
- [Narrator ] Welcome to
the New England Aquarium.
Here we have a selection
of its million or so
annual visitors.
And here we have Myrtle the Turtle.
But we're really here to
introduce you to Kathy Streeter.
Some people call her the seal whisperer
and this is her marine mammal team.
- Here at the aquarium
we have six harbor seals,
three sea lions and
four northern fur seals.
Some of the animals were rescued
and some of them were born here.
Ready?
Good!
- [Narrator] Like most aquarium trainers,
Kathy's team trains
their animals with food.
For example.
- We taught a harbor seal to
mimic the sound of our voice.
He can utter how are you?
- How are you?
- [Narrator] But the team
does something that most
aquariums don't:
they also interact with
their animals without food.
- We call it play.
So instead of us spending
the day dictating throughout
what we want them to do,
we are encouraging them to show us
what they would like us to do.
(soft music)
It's totally up to them.
- [Narrator] Tic tac toe?
- Right now we're teaching
her the strategy of
just going to the corners.
Good.
Where you gonna go?
Oh no, come here.
Yeah?
- [Narrator] Mirror mirror.
(soft music)
String on a stick.
- Luna loves to play
with string type things.
Good girl.
Ultimately I feel like it really
enriches the animals' lives
to be able to participate
with us in a whole different
type of interaction and
one that is just not based
on food.
So we use that as the
reinforcement instead of fish
and in Sierra's session
where she was doing the
initial stages of learning
how to play tic tac toe,
at some point she started to vocalize.
So she offered to do
vocalizations instead of doing
the tic tac toe.
So we learned through play,
what are their preferences.
(soft music)
The standard comment we
get from trainers that
visit from other aquariums
is that they're amazed
that we can spend time out
on exhibit with our seals
and sea lions without
having food to interact
with them.
Everybody would love
to be able to do that.
I think that play behavior for children,
for adults, and for animals
is all extremely valuable
in the same regards.
It just expands your brain.
(laughs)
(soft music)